regardez toutes les belles choses qu'on
fait on est envahi par les étrangers
les étrangers de plus en plus nombreux
en france
une idée qui traverse les âges alors
faisons le point les étrangers en france
il y en avait moins avant et bien c'est
plus compliqué d'abord une précision sur
la définition d'étrangers selon l'insee
toute personne qui n'a pas la
nationalité française et qui résident en
france est considérée comme étrangère et
en observant la première et la dernière
donnée de cette courbe il est clair que
la part de la population étrangère en
france a augmenté entre 1911 et 2015
passant de 3% à 6,7 pour ça il ya
beaucoup de trop et pourtant les arabes
suis d'accord avec elle
oui mais cette évolution est à
relativiser car depuis le début du 20e
siècle
la france a accueilli plusieurs vagues
migratoires la première illustré ici
entre 1911 et 1931
la part des étrangers est multiplié par
deux la france a besoin de bras après la
première guerre mondiale et dans le même
temps espagnol portugais et italien
quitte la misère de leur pays parfois au
péril de la chaque jour des groupes
s'enfonce vers la montagne il démine ils
vont chercher en france une vie plus
compatibles avec leurs goûts et leurs
aspirations
la crise économique de 1930 mais aussi
la seconde guerre mondiale vont ensuite
fortement ralentir l'immigration et même
provoqué des départs de france si bien
qu'en 1954 la population étrangère est
retombé à 4,1 pour cent
elle repart à la hausse dès 1962 après
la guerre d'algérie trois cent cinquante
mille algériens arrivent en france et la
cohabitation est parfois un peu
difficile des genres et de tous groupés
ensemble étaient répartis au milieu
d'une collègue de famille de celle où il
souhaite accepter une fusion n'est pas
raciste mais en habitat à côté de ces
gens-là d'hlm et devenons mois gérer
devient en 1981 de la part des étrangers
atteignait près de 7% de la population
française
elle repart ensuite à la baisse jusqu'à
la fin des années 90 suite à une vague
de naturalisation est de retour au pays
d'origine
mais à partir des années 2000 la
conjonction de crises en europe et
autour du bassin méditerranéen conduit à
une nouvelle arrivées d'immigrés et
quelques réticences performer
ça c'est un fait la france est bien
depuis plus d'un siècle une terre
d'immigration soumises à de nombreuses
vagues migratoires mais en matière
d'accueil des étrangers le pays reste
encore loin de certaines nations
européennes
selon l'insee en 2014 chypre la lettonie
et l'autriche étaient les trois
premières la france arrivée seulement à
la 9e place
[Musique]